what do a 5g network in ethiopia
a vaccine manufacturing plant in india
and a clean energy project in south
africa have in common
they are the battlegrounds in the us
government's effort to counter chinese
influence around the world they call it
build back better world the buildback
brighter world project should be high
quality and high standards this is not
going to be easy for the us government
china has been in this game for eight
years now and they've committed more
than 400 billion dollars for projects
the biggest u.s development agency has
only 60 billion dollars available so
they're cobbling together more money
with other countries so these are still
really early days but this competition
is starting to heat up
to understand where this all got started
you have to go back to beijing in 2013.
that's when the chinese government
pitched this project to go to developing
countries and build them infrastructure
they called this effort the belt and
road initiative and the deal was this
they would go to a developing country
and offer them a loan for an
infrastructure project and then they
would send a chinese company there to
build the railway port or whatever so
the chinese government called this a
win-win deal
countries like the us and its allies
said this wasn't a good deal
the interest rates were really high so
what happened since the biden
administration took over was they've
developed an alternative to the belt and
road project they say the deals would be
much more transparent and have better
quality better standards and would not
in debt these developing countries
what the us and its allies are trying to
do is not only challenge chinese
influence abroad but they're also trying
to pair it with some of their other
priorities including climate change a
bill back better role is going to show
that we can grow our economies
fight climate change and leave a better
cleaner more livable planet for all of
our children at the u.n climate change
conference in glasgow usn's allies
announced a new clean energy project in
south africa i hope it will be a
blueprint
for similar partnerships with other
countries they also send a signal to the
world saying hey china is not the only
country that will fund and build your
projects come to the u.s come to the uk
come to france we have these offers for
you too we'll give you loans we'll also
help you find a contractor to do these
projects we're open for business
now these are really early days and the
us hasn't always followed through on its
friendliness even though it says it
wants to be friendly and they're going
to have some challenges ahead uh in
rebuilding relationships with countries
like france for instance
so it remains to be seen whether these
developing countries will actually take
a serious look at the american offers
but this is going to be a really
interesting competition between the us
and its allies in china to see who can
win more influence you can build more
infrastructure projects in the
developing world
[Music]